[Music]
many big holiday meals wouldn't be
complete without a very small variety of
fruit
cranberries have made their way onto
dinner tables for generations
but not without a fight the berries have
a storied history with farmers adapting
to survive
in an ever-changing industry nancy chin
has the story
this was our original vlog as dick ward
weaves between his cranberry bogs
in carver massachusetts we kept building
pieces
the 80 year old is surrounded by the
labor
of a lifetime how many cranberries do
you produce here
roughly a hundred and fifty thousand
pounds ward has been farming this land
for more than five decades
a goal he set for himself when he was
still in high school
his farm now sits on 50 acres with
berries that need tending to for about
14 months before harvest
you can see the thickness of the vines
the bulk of his harvest is sold for
profit
the rest is processed by hand in their
cellar for
family and friends this is a well
picked over batch that's for sure
cranberry farming started here in
massachusetts the fruit
one of the few native to north america
the plants evolved when the glaciers
left 10 20 000 years ago
and the indigenous people use the
cranberry
is very much an integral part of their
life the cranberries are dry
for most of the year brian wick heads
the cape cod cranberry growers
association
helping navigate the group's 300 farmers
through an industry
constantly evolving what once was a very
much a
juice first forward industry has now
turned to the sweetened dried cranberry
and the fresh fruit
which was once a hundred percent of what
the consumption was is now about five
percent
the precious fruits grow in precarious
situations
where the season's harvest can be
destroyed by one bad storm
or one fatal mistake the great cranberry
scare of 1959
why was it so great so that was the
country's first
food scan a few shipments of cranberries
from the pacific northwest
tested positive for herbicide but when
the head of the u.s health department
said weeks before thanksgiving families
should avoid them to be on the safe side
the business instantly collapsed they
took them off the store shelves and it
devastated the industry
there were no basically no cranberries
consumed that year and it took
two or three years to start to slowly
build out of it we lost a lot of growers
that just
couldn't make it the industry eventually
recovered but it demonstrated just how
delicate the agricultural business could
be
still today breaking even is considered
a good year
in this 3.5 billion dollar industry
a far cry from when ward first started
our prices dropped
considerably we were getting
for a one pound box of cranberries like
70 cents a pound compared to how much
normally
now 15 cents a pound unable to stay
afloat
ward was seriously considering selling
his farm a few years ago
until he started harvesting something
new
would you be able to keep farming if it
wasn't for these solar panels
no absolutely not ward leases six acres
to a solar energy company
and he's not alone since he started
massachusetts
is now incentivizing farmers to install
solar panels while growing crops
underneath pioneering a dual use program
it's the first of its kind and allows
farmers
to continue farming under previous solar
programs we were losing farms completely
to solar they were no longer farming so
now with this program
the income that the grower can achieve
through the solar panels
is enough to keep their farm going but
they're still producing
their crop or raising livestock
underneath them for consumers it means
produce can stay local
and for ward it means the future in more
ways
than one we have 12 grandchildren
and we're very concerned with the future
of our planet so
carbon footprint means something to us
and now every day war takes pride in
being able to continue his work
and often enormous effort to produce
such a tiny fruit
80 years old and you're still hard at it
why why not say
you know what i think i'm done
because i couldn't picture myself
in a elderly mobile home park playing
shuffleboard
you have to keep going and he does it
alongside the next generations
his son steve is a cranberry grower and
his grandson
justin is getting into the business as
well ward and his wife judy
assured and seeing their legacy continue
she and i have handed the ownership
over to our sons but i still call her
shots
as you should for cbs this morning
saturday nancy chen carver massachusetts
and it's my understanding he likes
canned cranberries better than
canned cranberries are great yeah my
son's favorite good stuff
surprising though i would expect fresh
all right what a story all right well
from that taste of the holidays to a
sound of the season
silver bells and all other varieties
ring out a joyful noise this time of
year
we'll meet some of those who keep an
ancient art alive
you're watching cbs this morning
saturday